[Music]
welcome back
so we're talking about turbulent flows
and today should be a pretty fun lecture
so i'm going to walk you through a lot
of examples
of turbulence and just great movies and
visualizations of turbulent flows
why they're important how we can use
them as engineers
and i'll provide you with some open
source resources codes and databases
in case you're interested in getting
started doing research in this field
so i'm pretty excited about this one i
think this is going to be a lot of fun
and one of the things i love about fluid
dynamics and turbulence in particular
is all of the great movies and
visualizations um
so that that's going to be kind of fun
here in fact i'll share with you
um the the reason i got into fluid
dynamics in the first place at least i
joke this i
used to do more pure math i was sitting
in a in a restaurant with my wife
drinking a bowl of miso soup and i was
looking at the patterns
uh kind of you know churning patterns of
this this bowl of miso soup and i
thought
boy this is more interesting than you
know anything i'm working on right now
so i'm going to go study that so you
know this kind of beautiful
visually appealing movie nature of it i
think
is cool so we're going to have a lot of
that in this lecture before i start i
want to
um bring up this quote by feynman from
the feynman lectures that has
always stuck with me and i don't expect
you to read all of this um but i'll i'll
kind of walk you through it so
the test of science is its ability to
predict had you never visited the earth
could you predict the thunderstorms the
volcanoes the ocean waves the auroras
the colorful sunset
this is really a statement that even
though we know the navy or stokes
equations even though i can write down
the equations of fluid flows and i can
simulate them in a computer
it is very hard for us humans to know
before
seeing a phenomena whether it exists or
whether it's possible
and that's one of the things that's
intriguing about physics and fluid
dynamics in general
is there's a huge disconnect from our
equations
to all of the richness of reality okay
there's another great one here the next
great era of awakening of human
intellect may well produce a method of
understanding
the qualitative content of equations for
example if i just gave you the
navier-stokes equations
could you from just the equations know
that there are hurricanes
not today maybe that's the next great
awakening anyway i love this quote
so what we do is we try to understand
the complexity of the world through
analogies through examples of simpler
building block flows that we might be
able to understand
so i've walked you through this a little
bit in the previous lecture there are
lots of canonical example flows
and i'm going to go into every you know
each of these with a lot more detail in
this lecture we're going to watch movies
and walk through uh different key
aspects of why they're interesting
challenging and important so again
wake flows very important for
engineering
mixing layers you know this comes up
everywhere you'll see this in the cloud
sometimes if you look carefully enough
jets you know very impactful we live you
know in the jet
age okay so i'm going to walk through
lots of these examples kind of one by
one and i want to remind you
of course that we ultimately want to
deal with these very very complex
systems
we're going to analyze them by
constituent parts by these building
block pieces
uh and eventually we might want to do
something like modeling or controlling
these systems but we have to understand
the building blocks first
okay good so pipe flow a lot of this i
already told you in the previous lecture
a lot of history of fluid dynamics goes
back to pipe flows pumping water through
cities
and so pipe flow is still very important
today there's a really cool
video a lot of these come from the aps
division of fluid dynamics conference
and so you can find these and watch the
whole videos i'm just showing excerpts
where here they took a pipe and they
have these
four fans that they can accelerate uh
flow through the pipe to try to control
the turbulence to try to make it more
laminar to change the drag
of the fluid going through this pipe so
you see upstream
downstream here's the perturbed section
and at some point they're going to turn
on this controller here
and they're going to with the
perturbation change the nature of the
downstream
so just by by increasing
some property here with these fans they
are making the downstream
much more laminar and presumably this
has better profile for
things like drag okay so this is a
really cool example of a canonical flow
that has been extremely well studied
there are great researchers who have
spent
most of their career studying this one
canonical flow example
its stability its mathematical
properties its engineering properties
good wake flows again wake flows
are super um ubiquitous everywhere
and it's one of the first flows that we
deal with uh
at least as computational engineers
often we'll start by modeling
something like this the flow past a
cylinder at low reynolds number
and of course we're trying to use this
as an analog for more complex wake flows
like the wake behind a transport truck
or a boat or a plane
this is a turbulent wake um that was
collected experimentally
by my collaborator richard zeeman at tu
braunschweig
so wake flows are everywhere very
important
if you can control the wake uh more
efficiently
even a little bit you will save billions
uh tens hundreds of billions of dollars
annually just by reducing the drag uh
behind transport vehicles
okay uh i couldn't help this is a
pretty cool work i couldn't help but
include this work
where uh these researchers at imperial
college london
are actually analyzing the wakes behind
fractal geometries
so i showed you you know the wake behind
a cylinder or a d-shaped body
in this work they're looking at sorry
skipped
ahead in this work they're looking at
um
the wake behind you know a square a
circle
and then a fractal object and i think
this is super interesting there are
different drag profiles and
mixing and turbulence uh that you can
get with these fractal cross-section
wakes and so this is just a really cool
uh
avenue of work looking at these things
they actually do this experimentally
which i think is incredibly impressive
uh to get this kind of um this kind of
result
so okay good other examples where wake
flows are important uh
of course when you're flying
commercially
these large large commercial transport
jets will create
massive wakes behind them you see this
huge vorticity
uh generated by by the tip vortex from
the wing
this actually has huge impact for error
port scheduling
when a you know triple 7 or a 747
takes off or lands they have to wait for
minutes
before a smaller aircraft can take off
afterwards
because that vorticity is so large it
could flip
a smaller jet and things like this have
happened there have been accidents
because of wake vorticity
so understanding and characterizing and
control like mitigating this
could have you know it could make it so
that you take off faster and you can
have more
uh aircraft density at airports
good other examples the boundary layer
is one of the most
important flows so this is an experiment
i'm going to rewind
just so you see this the experimental
setup so boundary layers essentially
model
if you have a flat plate like let's
think of the surface of a wing
how does the flow become turbulent and
more and more complex as it accelerates
you know over that wing and so this is
great work
that i'm going to again pull this video
from the aps fluid gallery
where they have experimentally
characterized they experimentally
accelerate this
this plate through the water and you can
see
that as kind of the flow velocity or the
reynolds number gets higher
the turbulence gets more and more
complex and more
and the boundary layer also gets thicker
and so this has implications for
the drag on that surface whether or not
the flow will separate
which has huge impacts for lift as well
and these are extremely important
quantities to know and to be able to
predict
when you're designing an aircraft wing
are the mixing and the drag and whether
or not the flow is going to separate
because those are all critical for
safety and for efficiency
i like this next video because they're
going to put the
low velocity and high velocity on top of
each other so this is
slow and fast and you can see the change
in the nature of the turbulence
just by accelerating the flow to higher
reynolds numbers
so here it's much much more turbulent
but it's also
more uniform okay so that again has
pretty big
implications again you can watch this
whole video if you just go
through these links now that was
experimentally acquired
we also have the ability with high
performance computing
to simulate these boundary layers with
exquisite detail numerically
so to track every minor eddy and
horseshoe vortex across this entire
boundary layer
at relatively high reynolds numbers so
this is
a johns hopkins dataset turbulent
boundary
layer i think in the previous video i
showed you one from kth
but really you can do pretty amazing
things to probe
to probe these flows and get a really
high resolution picture
now what's difficult in simulations
that's easy in experiments
is getting really long time series to
simulate this flow
one snapshot might be you know hundreds
of megabytes or gigabytes or
tens or hundreds of gigabytes and you
know
simulating a short run might take
you know half a million cpu hours or
more i mean
i don't know off the top of my head it's
a lot
we but you can get exquisite 3d detail
across all of the scales whereas in
experiments it's much harder to get the
full you know detailed view in space and
in time
but you can run that experiment for
hours and hours and hours and collect
statistics
of what's happening for very very long
time series
so just in case you're you're curious
like
experiments and simulations are kind of
complementary there are things that
simulations can do that experiments
can't and vice versa so they're really
really important
to have both of these perspectives okay
uh cavity flows i think are super fun so
a cavity basically is a notch
or an empty space where you have flow
going over it
and these flows are super interesting so
you have
a sheer layer that's forming here and
there
are cavity resonances here that are
interacting with that shear layer
and if you if the flow is fast enough
you start getting acoustic radiation
into the far field and acoustic
radiation inside the cavity
and it turns out cavity flows are really
important because if you turn this
cavity upside down
it starts to look like the bombay doors
of a of an aircraft
and so i have a video i took from
chicagoland skydiving center
so the bombay doors are opening okay now
the inside of this airplane is a cavity
it's resonating there's recirculating
flow it's
acoustics are loud in this case they're
not dropping bombs they're dropping
people
but in any case the vibrations and the
unsteady fluid mechanics from that
cavity flow
can create huge acoustic vibrations
inside of this
cavity which in some cases might even
damage what's inside of there if you
have you know
ordinance inside of there they could be
vibrating and banging together and stuff
and so understanding modeling and
controlling cavity flows is a really
important
area of fluid dynamics actually this is
one of the the projects that my phd
advisor clancy rowley worked on
early in his career and made some really
really key advances in modeling
and understanding and controlling these
cavity flows
in the compressible regime super
impressive work
okay i'm just going to keep going
because i absolutely love these videos i
love canonical flows like this is what i
would do
in my spare time you know on a saturday
morning is just check out
a jet okay so this jet is absolutely
beautiful
you can again see this multi-scale
unsteady
nature of this thing and there's a lot
of flavors of jets this is one of the
harder
uh canonical problems because the jets
that we care about
out of you know actual jet engines at
uh subsonic transonic and supersonic
speeds
are very complicated they're typically
compressible so
uh you know you have density variations
you get acoustic radiation uh so
acoustic
uh energy is being you know scattered
off of this turbulent wake
and it's just a very very complex
multi-scale
uh three-dimensional flow lots of great
people work on jets and it's one of the
kind of
hardest and most interesting and very
important problems
again jet noise
directly affects tens of millions of
humans on earth
right so just within the the heathrow
flight path alone
or in the greater uh manhattan
or new york metropolitan area or los
angeles
there are tons of people whose lives are
directly affected by the noise that's
radiated from
jets carrying humans and cargo from one
place to the other
and so a better ability to model and
control
and suppress that jet noise would have a
direct
uh benefit in in human lives i mean one
of the reasons the concord
wasn't successful was because it was so
loud okay and it wasn't jet noise in
that case but
you know noise is a big problem people
can only handle so much
jet noise okay good
now mixing layers i really like mixing
layers because
this is actually from a dynamical system
from a mathematical standpoint
mixing layers is one of the most
interesting kind of
to study and to analyze from a stability
and dynamical systems point of view
so you can imagine uh following a packet
of fluid as it evolves along this this
mixing layer
and seeing kind of what bifurcations
occur because here it's very
linear and periodic uh unstable
instability
then you get vortex pairing this is the
kelvin uh
kelvin vortex
shedding you get this vortex pairing
where the frequency
halves so it's lower frequency and then
you get this vortex breakdown to chaotic
kind of turbulent regime in the wake so
very very interesting stuff happening
here i really like mixing layers
um and i've shown you all of these
canonical flows now i want to show you
a really really complex flow to kind of
motivate why you might actually want all
of those constituent
pieces to understand them because in a
real flow you're going to see all of
those pieces again
this is a really really cool simulation
by the kth
group just fantastic fluids researchers
and i'll actually talk about the code
they use to generate this in a little
bit
but this is the flow over um
a wing cross section so supposed to be a
piece
of this larger aircraft and this is a
full direct numerical simulation so
they're not approximating anything
they're
modeling all of the scales from biggest
scale to smallest scale of the entire
navier-stokes equations this is a
you know tour de force in modeling to do
this direct numerical simulation
uh and so they build this computational
domain
over this airfoil and soon you're gonna
see just this incredible complexity of
the turbulence evolving
and i'll walk you through how it relates
to some of those canonical flows
okay so you know and they're very
careful they have to be very careful
about
how they set up the computational domain
the boundary conditions
uh how many meshes 35 million core hours
75 terabytes of data for the simulation
and here is what it leads up to i love
this this is one of my favorites
so they've tripped the flow to
turbulence here with a body force
and you can just see this incredible
multi-scale complexity evolving
in the boundary layer so this is the
boundary layer flow
over kind of the flat or smooth part of
this
this airfoil so they have this
incredible boundary layer with the
the hairpin head vortices and the
multiscale developing
and thickening of the boundary layer at
the trailing edge
you'll see trailing edges are usually
characterized by mixing layers
because remember bernoulli you have
faster flow over the top
slower flow over the bottom when the
fast flow impinges
it creates this mixing layer type flow
right in the near wake
formation of a mixing layer and then
as you zoom out and start to go to
larger larger wake scales you start to
see the formation
of actual uh wake structures
just like those bluff body flows and so
that's really cool in this one flow
alone
you have three kind of different
canonical flows all interacting and
working together you have your boundary
layer flow
on the surface your mixing layer in the
near wake
and then you have the kind of carmen
vortex street type wake behavior
in the far awake and all of this is
important to understand
and to be able to model and predict and
control when you want to design
and control uh in real aerospace
applications
so very cool and this is really kind of
the state of the art of what's possible
you know maybe this was five years ago
so five years later maybe we can
simulate a little bit higher rentals
number a little bit more
complicated uh but this is pretty pretty
impressive
okay good uh so i think i've walked
through some of my favorite canonical
flows and hopefully convinced you that
these actually are
important they're challenging and they
culminate
when you put them together you can start
to describe really complex flows
now i'm going to walk through some of
the open resources that are available so
that you can get
working in this really really exciting
and important field
so one of the ones i use almost all the
time is the johns hopkins turbulence
database
databases there's multiple databases
this is
such a valuable resource in the fluids
community
um they have tons of different examples
from isotropic turbulence
channel flows uh magnetohydrodynamics
they have you know transitional boundary
layers this is an extremely
well thought of well-curated rich
turbulent data set set of data sets
where you can download this data and
start computing things and working on
these flows
yourself this is especially useful for
those of us who do data-driven methods
and machine learning you know extracting
coherent structures and patterns and
trying to build models
this is a playground of data now i will
warn you some of these things are pretty
hard to download
they're pretty big and so that can uh
that can get expensive
fast and uh just giving you one example
this is
a video of a visualization of a flow
from this turbulence data set so there
in this case
um looking at the multi-scale nature
that every time you zoom
into a vortex filament you're going to
see more scales of vortex filaments
and it's just really cool like you can
download this and play around with this
yourself
visualize analyze these flows so we're
going to zoom into this packet here
and look there's more filaments inside
so it's truly a multi-scale turbulent
data database
okay good there are lots of others i'll
try to put links in the
um in the comments and you know in a lot
of our papers we have
other resources so um there is a data
set called
hi-com h-y-c-o-m where you can download
atmospheric
sorry not atmospheric sea surface ocean
current
data for the entire globe you can get
you know
the flow field in the gulf of mexico
from satellite imaging
for decades at hourly resolution
it's incredible you can um
download the sea surface temperature on
the entire surface of the earth with
incredible resolution in space and time
so noaa and nasa have also released just
absolutely phenomenal databases
for atmospheric and geophysical flows
stanford has their own
set of databases so really lots of good
resources out there
codes let's say you want to generate
this data so downloading data is one
thing
but if you want to do control if you
want to do modeling if you want to do
predictions
sometimes you need to actually have the
code to generate data
dynamically okay so databases are what
my colleague barrett noak would call
postmortem data analysis sometimes we
want to analyze the living data
in an actual simulation
one of my favorites and the one that i
use all the time is this immersed
boundary projection method
it's a really quick easy way to simulate
laminar flows
this is based on an algorithm by
tyra and colonias and colonia centaira
really cool immersed boundary projection
method
and this code is on github by clancy
rowley so he developed this ibpm in c
plus very modular very easy to um to
modify to make the
the objects move to add control
uh to take the navy or stokes equations
and to analyze individual
components of those equations you know
pull out the linear component pull out
the diffusion term things like that
so really kind of uh easy entry point
to simulating at least you know these
kind of cool
laminar flows but moving geometries
another ubiquitous piece of software is
open foam
lots and lots of people use open foam
and you can simulate
very very complex geometries
three-dimensional flows
add in turbulence models i mean this is
a pretty sophisticated package
one of the ones that my lab likes a lot
and
you know my collaborators use a lot is
this neck
5000 code that is supported by argonne
national labs
anl.gov and so you can download
everything here it's completely open
and very well maintained by the
government this has kind of a long
memory so
this is going to be maintained for a
long time and again
uh that flow i showed you by the kth
group this
wing flow this was simulated in neck
5000
to the best of my knowledge and so this
is like a real
research production code where you can
go as complex as you want
parallelize i mean this is is heavy duty
stuff
and i know that my students and my
collaborators use this a lot
so very very cool cool code
okay good so hopefully i've convinced
you that flows are
just interesting really multi-scale
there's kind of these canonical example
flows
but real flows have bits and pieces of
all of them working together
and you can actually start simulating
and getting your hands dirty with data
and with codes yourself so i highly
encourage you to do that
and stay tuned we're going to have more
kind of in this general turbulence and
fluid dynamics
machine learning for fluid dynamics so
i'm really excited to see where this all
goes
thank you